Jacob do you have a favorite movie star
wars
shower which one which one now return
Jedi yeah thing you have to know Jake is
if you ask him then tomorrow it changes
like every single day it's his new
favorite thing I loved the movie it's
really incredible I couldn't wait to see
it because I loved the book I almost
feel like this is a film you don't want
to tell people too much about do you
agree that you don't want to give away
too much before you go in yeah I think
that those that love the book
really enjoy watching the movie unfold
but there's been um quite a few people
that I've spoken with that went in
completely blind and it's like a
completely new experience yeah so you
kind of get to watch this mystery unfold
do you remember how Alice wasn't always
in Wonderland she fell down down down
deep in a hole right well I wasn't
always in room what was the most helpful
VA to get into the mindset of yoga there
was just so much that I had to do in
order to try and understand or like get
at least a little bit of a grasp of her
so I spoke with a trauma specialist
about kidnapping situations and confined
living situations sexual abuse the being
pregnant and then having a pregnancy on
your own like imagining what that was
like kind of informed a lot about I
about her strength and what she had been
through hanging with him
I mean creating a whole world with him
how did you make the room your own well
we built toys oh and I decorated a few
stuff yeah she made some drawings we
tried to do drawings of one another
which I think his were better of me than
mine were if his mind were not very good
of you let me have a big what years to
stay I know I know I'm sorry okay you
have a favorite activity that you do on
set in downtime he would do this thing
all the time where he would just like
become dead weight and just like fall
over and ice and just always expect that
I would catch him and he would do it
over and over and over again please
don't do it right now and he never felt
thank goodness whoever's like spent
every second together so you get very
comfortable and it becomes very easy to
poke fun at one another it's a we just
sort of entertainers no hook me
yeah exactly yeah luckily you can
definitely tell that relationship comes
through in the movie congratulations to
you both absolutely loved room and make
sure you get your tickets on Fandango
and si room yeah